beijing's one china policy could make
conflict about the future of taiwan
inevitable
and this is what it might look like
on tuesday taiwan began live fire drills
to showcase the self-proclaimed island
nation's defensive power
days after some of the largest military
exercises china has ever conducted china
has used the drills
in its military playbook to prepare for
the invasion of taiwan
it is conducting large-scale military
exercises and missile launches as well
as cyber attacks disinformation campaign
and economic coercion in an attempt to
weaken public monorail in taiwan taipei
says it won't be intimidated even as
china breaches the unofficial median
line down the taiwan strait
we need to counter the blockade imposed
by the chinese military on us and
today's exercise is to let china know
that we are prepared i hope both sides
can exercise restraints fighting a war
is not good for the ordinary people
top officials from both sides are at
odds we are just ordinary people and
there's nothing we can do if anything
happens in the future we can't do
anything either
the latest flexing of muscles follows
u.s house speaker nancy pelosi's visit
to taipei
a show of support for taiwanese
independence that china says directly
contravenes beijing's historical claim
to the island
the u.s position china is using the
diplomatic visit to pick a fight clearly
the prc is trying to coerce taiwan
clearly they're trying to coerce
the international community and all i
say is um we're not going to take the
bait and it's not going to work
so it's a manufactured crisis that that
doesn't mean we have to play into that
i think it would only play to beijing's
advantage what we'll do instead is to
continue to fly to sail and to operate
uh wherever international law allows us
to do so and that includes in the taiwan
strait and we will continue to stand by
our allies and partners uh in in the
region
the war games have disrupted shipping
and air traffic in a region crucial to
global trade
more worrying perhaps beijing and taipei
are turning up the heat on another
brewing global conflict zain basravi
al-jazeera